[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
uh tonight i want to start what's going
to be a series uh about one of my
favorite openings uh to play against
with white so of course i'm a d4 player
with white there are a lot of things you
have to deal with as a d4 player
probably the most fun is the king's
indian defense so this is a pretty
controversial opening it's been played
a ton at the top level but these days
with the advents of super strong
computers
people are starting to question whether
or not this is a playable opening at the
highest level of chess for black uh it
tends to be a very risky opening uh
historically uh players like kasparov
have done very very well with it uh and
it makes for a very very fun game as as
we're going to see here tonight
so to start with i want to go through uh
some of the different lines that i'm
planning to cover
talk about
all of these different options that
black is going to have in the king's
indian against the way that i'm going to
recommend to play and hopefully by the
end of the night you guys have a really
good feel a really good understanding
for what the plans are in these kings
indian positions
and how we can make them turn out well
for for white especially in the lines
that i'm going over tonight i'm gonna be
talking about an idea that hasn't really
been popular at the top level uh since i
think the 80s and 90s is when people
sort of realized
maybe this idea is not so good that
being said i have played against this
particular move numerous times uh in my
chess career so it's definitely still
still a mainstay
um that being said though again like i
said i want to start out with just kind
of an overview of the opening talking
about what's going on what kind of
positions we're aiming for with white
and what sort of all the options are
going to be so like i said this is a d4
opening and the king's indian of course
comes about after knight f6
c4 g6
knight c3 and then for some reason the
move order i put in was d6 here of
course you can get here via bishop g7
e4
or d6 e4 which is what i put in now of
course d5 here is the grunfeld not
talking about the grunfeld talking about
the king's indian okay so d6 e4 bishop
g7 bishop e2
is the line that i am going to recommend
so already we've made sort of a big
decision now
like i said this is a broad broad
opening there are a ton of different
things you can do including f3 the
sameish you can play h3 i think this is
the macaganov uh you can play f4 here
you can play bishop d3 and ag e2 bishop
g5 there are a ton of things that you
can do against the king's indian i am
wrecking recommending i guess the the
orthodox the classical way of playing
which is to go with bishop e2 and knight
f3
uh here black castles
we're gonna go knight f3
and now already we have a big decision
point for black um i have the the little
database open here on my screen which
you can just barely see i think in in
the live audience and it's saying e5 of
course is by far the main move this is
the main line of the king's indian we're
going to be talking about some positions
after e5 today
but black does have a variety of
sidelines that i want to get to in in
due time those include this move knight
a6 knight bd7 bishop g4
c5
c6 even knight c6 here and queen e8 are
all going to get their moment in the sun
i even went so far as to say i'm going
to talk about this move a5 as well
and a lot of these side moves are going
to have similar ideas and you'll get
into similar positions but they do have
some independent value so we'll talk
about them eventually for now though i
want to mention e5
our plan is going to be to castle
against this move so so far so normal
right we put all of our pieces on very
reasonable squares black uh fiancee
played knight f6 and castled king's side
and now is finally fighting back in the
center with this move e5
common question i get asked by beginners
you know is this pawn hanging the answer
is as always kind of right so it looks
like there's just too many attackers
here you can take d8
take e5
but what's going to happen here is
knight takes e4 when now you see the
point of the tactic is uh sort of being
revealed so you can't just win a pawn
against e5 which is why we're going to
castle
black gets the piece back and black i
think is is probably better in this
position
um
okay so we castle instead
now today we're gonna be focusing on the
main move which is knight c6 but again
uh both on move six and seven you're
gonna have a lot of transpositions here
but again these moves like knight a6
knight d7
c6 and now even a few extra options like
knight h5 and bishop g4 are going to
become very very relevant and we'll talk
about those in due time but today as i
said we're focusing on knight c6
now we're going to play d5 against this
and this is sort of the iconic classical
king's indian position after d597 this
is where uh players have been battling
for at least the past 50 years over what
is going on in in this position
i think this is probably the most
testing variation against the king's
indian defense
but it's also very testing for white so
who here is familiar with this position
and the plans that are involved
anybody
this is totally new okay uh that's okay
and then brian you said you've seen this
before right
i think i've seen yeah i mean other
people play this before yeah
it's basically
yeah that's exactly right so there's
this old adage uh
in chess
that says you should play where your
pawns point
now what does that mean really it's it's
saying you should play on the side where
you have more space
of course space is a good thing to have
in chess it gives your pieces more room
to maneuver
and
when you have more space that's the side
of the board you want to play on because
if your pieces have more room to
maneuver then you can outmaneuver your
opponent you can target their weaknesses
better and you can win on the side of
the board where you have more space
and so by playing on the side of the
board where your pawns points in this
case of course black's pawns point
towards the king's side so as brian said
black is going to be playing on the king
side going to try to be expanding on the
king's side of the board getting more
space in playing for checkmate meanwhile
you know it's a little bit less clear
which side of the board white's pawns
point to but since we are ready to
expand further with these types of moves
on the queen side then the queen side is
where white has more space and that's
the side of the board where white is
going to try to win
so
to that effect these are going to be the
main ideas we focus on in the lecture
tonight we're not going to get through
all of the relevant variations here
because there's too much for one lecture
but we'll definitely get a get started
on it
so in this position i am recommending uh
the the old main move that they've been
doing for years and years and years
which is knight to e1 now fans of
vladimir kramnik might be familiar with
his move b4 which is the bayonet attack
and this is a very good line but i think
knight e1 is the best move that's my big
claim so today we're going to look at 91
and now the the last big decision point
here for black after knight e1 uh
knight to d7 these days is considered
the main move it's considered the best
move for black but today i want to focus
on the secondary move knight to e8 but i
want to tell you why i want to focus on
it here so against knight to d7 i'll
show you some spoilers i'm going to be
recommending bishop e3
and now why is black always moving this
knight how does that make any sense does
anybody anticipate black's idea here
based on what i've said
yeah f5 black wants to expand on the
side of the board where he has more
space take even more space and
eventually try to checkmate us
so after f5 the point of knight e1 is
also revealed we want to shore up our
center with f3
now black's going to go f4 bishop f2 and
the main line is going to come with g5
and like i said black is coming for us
over here and just to reveal
uh
my point the the line i'm recommending
is c5 in this position now black's only
serious move is knight takes c5 and then
we can go b4 and we get into some very
complex variations there
um
what's the idea of all of this well the
idea is you cannot play knight to d7
because after knight to b5 i'm targeting
your c7 pawn
so keep that in mind the the main move
i'm recommending against the main line
is uh revolving around this idea of
targeting c7 so that's why i actually
want to start with this move knight to
e8 uh it's a lot like knight to d7 but
now as you'll notice one of the big
points of 98 is black is you know
preemptively uh cutting us off uh here
by defending this c7 pawn the knight on
d7 of course not going to defend c7 then
at an e8 defend c7 so we are gonna have
to go for sort of the
uh more classical ideas against um
against black's play so that's why i
want to start with this this is going to
be sort of the king's indian at its
purest black is coming for us on the
king side we are coming for black on the
queen's side and we're going to see who
wins the race
um i have good news for you guys it's us
uh so i want to start with uh what
happens if black sort of plays this 98
idea
which we'll get to that position right
away and then plays as if uh he had
actually played knight to d7 just sort
of pretends it's business as usual and
tries to come after us
so we know black's idea black is doing
this and this and this and coming after
us so what do you think white should be
playing for in the meantime
what is white's idea gonna be
we know it's on the queen side
but how do we
actually get some active play
yeah we want to do a pawn storm we
absolutely do want to do a pawn storm so
what is the the key pawn break going to
be
and in this case
what do i mean by a pawn break that
means when you put your pawns in tension
with your opponent's pawns where they
can capture each other and break open
the position
yeah either the b or c file i'm looking
at this move c5 c5 is going to be our
key move here now why is c5 the key move
that's what puts the pawns in tension
that's going to introduce our main ideas
either capturing on d6 opening up the c
file and allowing us
us to
more effectively bring our pieces in
it's also going to introduce ideas of
potentially one day pushing this pawn to
c6 and targeting these other pawns on
the queen side so c5 the c pawn is what
it's all about
and with that in mind there are a few
common ways for white to get developed
here one is bishop e3 one is knight d3
you'll notice that both of these moves
help defend the c5 square there's also a
clever idea with f3 that i'm actually
not going to recommend because i don't
think it's very good but i like this
move bishop e3 brings our piece into the
game helps it target the queen side
where you want to be playing and
furthermore it helps defend the c5
square for the c5 break now black is
going to push with f5 it's really the
only sensible move here
and we are gonna play f3
now there are a couple uh important
ideas that i want to talk about at a
later date uh including c5 and king h8
where black tries to be clever and leave
this pawn on f5 to target our center a
little bit more but for today we're
focusing on the main plan which is f4
now thanks to f3 we can tuck our bishop
back on f2
and black is going to continue out now
with either g5 or h5 now these moves
actually don't have any independent
value whenever black plays h5 pretty
much 100 of the time you know we play
the same move which is going to be c5
100 of the time black is going to follow
up with g5
so no independent value there so we'll
focus on g5 which is the more flexible
option
now like i said i'm recommending this
move c5 this is going to be the key
focus of the lecture today all the moves
up until this point have been more more
or less pretty linear right black wants
to go f5 f4 g5 white wants to develop
the the pieces we need to go f3 uh to
shore up our center and so it's very
very linear right the players don't
deviate too much these are the plants
but from here black is going to have a
few different options and we're going to
see that there's sort of something wrong
with all of them so what do i want to
look at so i want to look at
ways for black to achieve the g4 push
that's what it's all going to be about
for black for us it was c5 by virtue of
having the white pieces we got our break
in first for black it's going to be
achieving g4
of course black's not going to do it
right away we would actually capture
this pawn for free so black needs to
prepare this move and we're gonna see
that there's a few different ways black
can can go about doing that
so i think uh potentially the the best
way for black to play is to go rook f6
to g6 h5 and try to play g4 like this
why do i think this is the best way well
it's uh the fastest way for black to
achieve this break and it's keeping in
line with the ideas of knight to e8 by
playing 98 black opens up this avenue
for the rook and allows himself this
fast way to go for g4 now to start with
i want to look at what happens if black
takes the more normal approach sort of
the knight d7 approach which is to play
knight g6 and take just a few more turns
to go for g4 you get this sort of more
solid setup with black you get more
pieces involved but you're not
threatening g4 quite as quickly so i
want to start with this
against this knight g6 idea black is
taking so long to play this move g4 that
we are actually going to have
a way to win outright on the queen side
before black can even think about uh
about playing this move
so before i reveal the idea i want to
ask you guys just to take a second here
and think about our our options in this
position white has tried a lot of
different moves here
and before i show what i think is the
best line i think it's worthwhile to
look at the different ideas and
understand why some are correct and some
aren't so to get you started of course
we're looking at the queen side of the
board we're looking at ways to open up
files over here ways to target blacks uh
queenside pawns so let's see if you guys
can come up with just a couple ideas for
what white wants to do over here on the
queen side
what should we be aiming for
so anything we can do to provoke
weaknesses to get our pieces uh to
invade on the queen's side to open up
files these are the ideas you want to
look at
yeah so rook c1 is a key move in our
main uh variation against knight d7
and it's a good idea here
it's not not a bad move by any means but
i'm going to argue
that we can do better and the reason for
that again is because this knight e8
move is specifically targeted at
controlling the c7 square
so because our opponent has played in a
way that's designed to control these
squares in the c file it's better
actually in this case to
go
target some some other squares
but yeah rook c1 is a very important
idea to the position so it's good to
understand rook c1 normally a good idea
and understand the specifics because of
98 maybe we look for something else
c6
yeah so c6 is another critical idea in
the position we would love to see pawn
takes c6 when we could play pawn takes
c6 and now what have we done we've
opened up
this diagonal for a bishop we've
weakened
the light squares in the position
for black
and we've given ourselves some some very
good ideas you know even for example
just coming down the board with our
pawns playing v6 is going to be a nice
winning plan for us however there's
something wrong with c6 what might black
do if we were to play c6 right away
yeah that's exactly right uh you know
the adage you want to play on the side
where you have more space you also want
to open things up on the side where you
have more space so if black is able to
lock things down that's going to be
advantageous for for black against c6
but again c6 is an important idea it's
just that there's
sort of one problem with it
so no one's mentioning maybe the the
most forcing move
yeah so you could just take on d6 right
so this is definitely worth looking at
and it's always going to be a critical
option for white
now what happens if we take and black
takes back are there any interesting
options here for white how can we make
use of all this pressure we have on the
queen side
yeah you could start launching some
ponds down the board but there's
actually a way that white can
immediately provoke a weakness in the
position so as it sits these pawns here
are well positioned to keep the white
pieces out but we can force them to move
and provoke some weaknesses to give our
own pieces some squares
yeah knight b5 is again a critical idea
in this position
why because we're targeting this a pawn
and we're either going to capture this a
pawn outright which of course weakens
the squares or black is going to either
move the a pawn or the b pawn and either
move is going to give us a lot of a lot
of options here
but sadly again there is sort of a
problem with our place so after a6
white has this really nice idea of going
knight a3 and if black sort of continues
business as usual we can go knight c4
and then plant one of our pieces either
the the knight or the bishop both tend
to be good on to b6 and white is
probably winning in this position but
black does have a nice resource here in
the form of this move b5
and b5 it looks like it makes more
weaknesses and in fact it does but it is
actually going to slow down our play
quite a bit we no longer have this
knight c4 to b6 idea and white is sort
of sad about this knight on a3 you know
it takes some time to try to do
something like this and maybe even after
we get here the knight isn't crushing on
c6 right we need to win on the queen
side before black gets after us
so with all of these ideas in mind there
is sort of a way to uh there is the the
perfect improving move here
for white
so let's think about it let's say if cd6
cd6 knight b5 a6 there's a move that
helps prevent b5 there's a move that's
good against this b6 idea as well
and even if knight takes here which
we'll see is an important idea there's a
move that would be useful to have in
this position
and so because that move is useful
literally everywhere we should just play
it right now so does anybody know the
mystical magical move that i'm talking
about that would be useful everywhere it
helps prevent b5 it helps play against
b6 it even helps us against this move
knight takes d6
i'm guessing
yeah so queen b3 is always going to be
double-edged the reason being your queen
is useful to help stop g4
and so we might want to leave our queen
on d1 for as long as we can because if
we're stopping g4 then that gives us
more time on the queen side to do what
we want to do
some other move
yeah so knight d3 is not a bad move here
um but it's
sort of not again not stopping moves
like b5 right
a4 is is the best move in this position
and it's the move that i'm going to
recommend
so how does a4 help us everywhere well
let's take a look let's just play a move
for black we'll play h5 again let's say
we go down these same lines right cd6
knight b5
now if b6 really easy to see how a4
helps us we're immediately going to play
this move a5 open up this a file and bam
we crashed through on the queen's side
we won the race black didn't get off the
ground on the king side we're already
forcing black to play where we are going
to be the strongest
if a6 now again this knight a3 idea is
going to be very very strong if you come
to c4 and you cannot play b5 to stop us
and lastly if knight takes d6
uh we'll see that knight to b5 is going
to be a very strong move in this case
knight to b5 uh and how does the a pawn
help us well of course if takes we're
going to take back with the pawn and
again
bam we have cracked open the a file and
so a4 is such a great move that you want
to play it
right away because it helps us
everywhere it's always going to be a
useful move and we'll see in this case
that we might even have a better idea
than taking on d6 that's how strong this
a4 move is
so with a4 i'm going to like take a look
at the main move which is rook f7 so h5
is more or less the same you can play
pretty much the same way against it
because in the long term you know you
can throw in h5 at any point but black
is is playing for this sort of plant
either bishop f8 or bishop f6
moving the bishop playing rook g7
um so now again we could very much go
for these ctx d6 plans and these plans i
think are going to be a bit better for
white but i think white has an even
better way of playing here which is a5
so keep these planes in mind they're
going to be really important a little
bit later on but in this case we're
going for an even stronger plan in the
form of c6
so we remember the c6 idea from when we
were brainstorming earlier and like i
promised it's a relevant idea uh we just
wanted to put our pawn on a5 first so
that black doesn't have that option of
pushing past us now of course we are
immediately going to be able to capture
and black is is dead dead lost if you
play play b6 you cannot take with the a
pawn and you don't really want to take
with the the b pawn either
let me just ask the computer really
quick how do we prove it
uh yeah queen b3 is is plus three b4 is
also plus three uh every everything is
just totally totally winning um i think
we can even
uh think about taking on b6 soon i guess
not yet but knight b5
okay computer's suggesting nonsense
let's say black plays a human move yeah
again this this is uh a big idea for us
um so c takes b definitely not going to
be an option which means b6 is not an
option
which means black does have to sort of
go for these unfortunate ideas of taking
on c6 or just sort of ignoring the
situation on the queen side
so again how did we get here we started
in this 98 line we followed this linear
path
g5 is the most flexible c5 and now we're
looking at this knight g6 move uh by
playing knight to g6 black has sort of
already sealed his fate he's going to be
too slow with g4 so we can go a4 a5 and
c6 against pretty much whatever black is
going to be doing
at any moment of course though we're
looking for ways to open up the position
on the queen side
um so let's look at b take c6 first this
is the only thing that's been tried in
uh practice there's a game between
a couple of random 2200s here so it's
going to go bc6 d takes c6 of course
now black is still going for this plan
of g4
and white played very simply here and
actually very very well with b4
black tried to develop with bishop e6
going for d5 and then this game pretty
much immediately ended after g4 takes
knight f6
h3 shoring up the position again black
is just way too slow with things like h5
we just immediately are winning heavy
material on the queen side so black
tried this as a sacrifice but it's just
not good enough
d5 ed5
and eventually bishop b7 and this this
game is is just over um
we can play through the rest really
quickly white took on a8
and
gave some material back
it didn't matter
black actually already resigns in this
in this position that's just how bad it
is for black
um okay
so that's bc6 so how did white win this
game we just go b4 and play over here on
the queen's side black played bishop b6
allowing this bishop in with bishop b7
if black doesn't do that how do we want
to win
um
this is the point where i haven't
totally prepared this i imagine we can
just go bishop c4 check queen b3 check
and
b b5 b6 is is going to be very very
strong
let's check really quickly just to make
sure i'm not lying to you guys okay
knight d5 is strong b5 is strong i
imagine queen b3 is also very strong
yeah white white is doing very very well
everywhere i think b5 is the easiest to
understand so let's let's point this one
out
okay knight d5
yeah knight f6
and b6
so like i said we got this pawn on c6
and now we're just pushing through on
the queen side looking for ways to open
things up and it's like plus
plus two plus one point five plus plus
two very very good
um
okay now the computer says knight f6 is
the best move so we'll take a quick look
at this
apparently this position has been
reached but not by this move order and
here i'm going to recommend this move
queen b3 now because it actually makes a
very distinct threat and after queen b3
we're going to very very similar
positions where black is now forced to
take on c6
and in this case the only try for
counter play is with d5 we've already
stopped bishop e6 we're threatening
bishop c4 so d5 and now we just take and
here you can take with the queen take
with the pawn everything is is totally
totally winning just plus two plus two
everywhere
um okay
so that is the plan against knight g6
here so once again to summarize we go a4
a5 we followed up with c6 and then
depending on what black does we find
some way to crack things open on the
queen side and we basically just win
so questions from here or questions
about the general ideas before i move on
to the next plan
is this kind of making sense what we're
going for
all right i love it i love it
okay
so what if black is smarter than that
what if black instead of playing knight
g6 going for slower plans tries to
immediately come get us with h rick f6
to g6 h5 and g4
that is the next question
so let's talk about it
so once again we get here from knight e8
bishop e3 f5 f3 f4 bishop f2
and c5 after g5 and now again we are
looking at
what i think the best way of playing is
which is with rook f6 and h5 you can
kind of transpose these moves doesn't
matter so much
uh so once again
remembering all of our various ideas
what's the superstar move that is useful
everywhere
a4 always a4 so we play it again here
no reason not to now black goes rook f6
um now quickly let's take a look at what
happens if we try the same idea we go a5
rook g6
and now we try c6
well in this case
black has left this knight on e7 and
this idea is not going to work in time
not only that but let's say we play like
b4 or something black very much is
playing this move g4 right away as fast
as he can and he's breaking through on
on the king's side now and we have
ourselves a fight which is not what
we're looking for we're looking for
winning not a fight
so this a5 c6 idea is is not going to do
it for us anymore so what were the other
ideas that that we talked about
what what moved those sort of
focus around
how are we provoking all these
weaknesses
yeah this knife b5 idea
um
which maybe you can play it immediately
but i'm not going to recommend that i
think it's it's good to just capture
here right away so we're going to take
on d6 the idea being we're opening up
this bishop along this diagonal and now
there are two big moves for black i'm
going to look at c takes d6 first and
then we'll flip on over to another
chapter for knight takes c6 so c takes
d6 this move seems pretty natural
black leaves this knight in a nice
defensive position guarding against c7
in the d6 square and you know
potentially allowing it to jump back to
the king's side
excuse me sorry
and then black again is planning to
follow up rook g6 g4 get g4 in as fast
as possible
uh now what was the the follow-up move i
think you already shouted it
out knight b5 that's what we're going
for here so knight b5
now black again has three three options
basically you can go a6
to save your a pawn forcing your knight
back you can go b6 to save your a pawn
or you can ignore us and let us take
your a pawn
sort of the three options so we're going
to look at those three various options
in practice i think we've only gotten
here a few times
and black has tried to save the pawn in
all three cases so let's take a look at
a6 first i think this is the most
natural
so a6
now of course which square do we want to
go back to
a3 or c3
yeah definitely a3 because again we're
heading for c4 going into the b6 square
so what's black's plan here
so he would he would have liked to play
b5 but we have actually prevented that
with our useful move a4 he can't stop us
from getting to c4 play b5 we just take
it and again our goal is just to open up
files open things up over here and then
we we basically just win um so b5 not
going to be playable
yeah that's right again he's going for
g4 we know what his plan is so he goes
with g6 again g4 here
is upon sacrifice and not going to be
good that's why black is doing this rook
f6 g6 thing so rich g6 now what's our
plan
we want to invade on our newly made
weaknesses so how do we do
that knight c4 all of our moves are very
very logical you understand each of them
have this purpose of advancing our plan
on the queen side
uh so knight c4
and then
uh
i did put two moves in here really the
only relevant thing is going to be g4
you know i took a quick look at what
happens if black just passes but you
basically do the same thing so bam g4
black is coming after us
um now the good news is there are a
couple ways to win here um this this
position has been reached once in
practice again between
uh a random 2200 and a 2400 and i
actually like the way that white played
in the game he didn't go on to win the
game but he got a very much winning
advantage so we could go knight b6 and
this move is very very good i would even
say this move is basically winning but i
like this move bishop b6 instead so why
bishop b6 well our bishop might turn out
to be a liability on the f2 square black
is hoping to play g3 targeting the
bishop and the pawn and maybe we're not
so happy with uh black getting that move
with tempo so bishop b6 is really nice
to get the bishop out of dodge
queen to d7 is the only safe square for
the queen
and then the clever clever idea is to
now secure a bishop on a5 now that we've
put this queen onto d7 bam knight b6 is
a massive threat forking the queen and
rook
um so once again we're here we have our
weakness we looked for a way to invade
we found knight a3 to c4 and then we
uh sneak our bishop away tuck him on a5
and we're threatening this right away if
black goes like g3 or something we can
and will go knight b6 capturing one of
these pieces we're not so scared of
takes we're not going to take that pawn
back though we're going to use it as a
shield and white is is just winning
um so black should defend the rook goes
rook b8 we're going to go knight b6
anyways now queen to d8
and at this point just to show you some
example moves we just bring our rook to
the c file black comes out with bishop
to d7 and now there are a ton of
different ways to play here in the game
white played king to h1 trying to sort
of prepare for black on the queen side
or king side i think that queen b3 is is
just the the simplest way to play
let's say g takes f3 uh we can take on
d7
take on f3
and now just for example even the a6
pawn is falling black is black is losing
pretty much everywhere in in this
position just just losing let's let's
check what the computer thinks
um plus two and it wants to go b5 which
is sort of ridiculous we we can actually
just take this
um
go bishop before go king h1
really whatever we want to do and it's
it's plus two pretty much everywhere you
can play pretty much anything here you
have a winning position just don't hang
check me how are we gonna secure our
king we'll go rook g1
and h3
and our king is gonna be safe now it's
already plus three
okay
so
questions
there
questions
um
here about why white is winning how
white is winning
how we got here
anything for me
okay good so once again to recap
how did we get here
black went for the more uh
the the faster idea
of rook f6 to g6 with h5 going for the
quick g4
this successfully prevents our plan of
a5 c6 this knight here is still
defending the pawn and black is much
faster so we go to the other planes we
go to takes on d6 with knight b5 once
again now of a6
we're coming knight e3 to c4 we're going
bishop b6 invading on the queen side and
we we did it we win we opened things up
and black is not uh getting anywhere on
the king's side in time
so that was asics
now let's take a look at b6 now
hopefully you guys can anticipate the
way we want to play here
how can we open things up after b6
trying to stunt our bishop
yep exactly we go a5 we want to open the
file open the diagonal and get after our
opponent
and it's already real real bad for for
black if bishop d7 well first of all it
takes
we are going to take on a7 and this is
very very good
um if bishop d7 which is a better try we
are just going to take on b6
take on a8 and play queen b3 and again
once our opponent's pieces start sort of
coming to this side of the board uh it's
it's gonna go it's going to go our way
just some example moves we can come this
way we can bring the rook in we can take
this pawn on b6 it's it's just losing
for for black we we win the fight we win
the race we're playing on the queen side
we where our position is is strongest
so that's b6 not the most testing move
now last but not least what happens if
black ignores us right doesn't go a6
doesn't go b6 says whatever you can have
my a pawn i don't care about the a pawn
i care about checkmating you
so how do we you know make weaknesses
here if black doesn't defend the pawn
oh and there's a good question in in the
chat as well
yeah you just simply take the pawn
it's exactly right
you take the pawn black is going to try
to save this light squared bishop
because it's a very important piece to
attacking on on the king's side let's
say bishop d7 and then we can actually
insist on getting rid of this bishop
with bishop b5 and
we're now actually following a game the
game went g4
uh bishop d7 queen d7 and now king h1
and uh in the game he played h4 which
was very very bad because we can just
take on on g4
i thought g3 was a better try but now
we're just going to play bishop to b6
and after knight c8 we can take and we
are actually gonna play h3
um just completely locking down the
king's side making sure our king is safe
forever and then winning the game
now this h3 idea is actually why this
light squared bishop is so so important
in the king's indian
because
against h3 it's really important for
black to be able to play bishop takes h3
to sort of
get the the last defenses around the
white king open without this bishop
takes h3 idea uh black is is pretty much
helpless against our setup it's it's
nearly impossible to to actually get to
the white king in this position it's
gonna take you like eight tempe to try
to organize this and in the meantime
white is is gonna win on the queen side
um and that's just about it so the key
thing to remember if they ignore you is
to snag this bishop with bishop b5
and then um yeah this king h1 move is
good it's actually not forced by any
means like bishop b6 is also fine here
really anything is fine here
um and then remembering this nice idea
of going h3 to lock things down
um okay
so that is the quote-unquote better idea
for black of going uh rook f6 to g6 with
with h5 right rather than going a5 c6
like we do against knight knight to uh
g6
in this case we're going to take on d6
go knight b5 we provoke
irreparable weaknesses in black's camp
and then we use those weaknesses to win
so once again a6 is the main move we go
knight a3 heading for c4
then we go bishop b6
and with knight b6 we we get our winning
advantage again eventually we're looking
to take this bishop and have these nice
ideas of of h3 to sort of secure the win
and i was looking at again this move
queen b3
now again why is black not going uh with
g3 here
well we are actually thinking about
taking this bishop and going h3 again
it's it's the same idea that uh i was
talking about before with that bishop
dead we can lock things down on the
king's side
that's why i looked that's why i put the
move in gf3 and again we're going to
take off this bishop
and this pawn
and again we're winning on the queen
side just winning on the queen side here
if black ever plays this move h4 by the
way again important to play um
well hold on we can't play h3 okay h4 is
hanging in this position but why is king
h1 getting played all the time well it's
to meet this idea of h4 if you ever can
play it with h3
so we're not pins and we can again
lock things down on the king's side now
that the light squared bishop is dead
however in this position
probably not a good idea to play h3
because black can take it but probably a
good idea just to capture the free pawn
okay
so there you have it that is pretty much
uh
everything you need to know about knight
e8 where black is recapturing on d6 with
with the pawn however there is of course
another idea that i have yet to mention
which is what happens when black takes
back with the knight
so
this move uh on a surface level looks
sort of anti-positional right because
it's leaving this e5 pawn sort of
undefended it's breaking up black's huge
pawn chain over here on the king's side
but it comes with the benefit of
activating this piece a little bit
right this piece is going to be a little
bit active it's not going to be purely
defensive
on e8s and it's also going to open up
some extra avenues for black's queen for
example
uh to come into the game and it's going
to defend some other squares on the
queen side from from this d6 square
now let me
switch chapters here so i have all my
moves
um
so here we are rook f6 and h5 and then
knight takes d6 rather than c takes d6
so uh
in this position
a lot of the top players in the database
are playing this move knight to b5 which
is a really really good idea
we saw this idea before it worked really
well for us so it makes sense that we're
thinking about playing it here as well
and i think this move is very very
strong except for one nice defensive
idea for black so in the database pretty
much everybody is going a6 here which i
think is a very bad move knight takes d6
is going to be strong and after c takes
d6 uh black is going to have a lot of
the same problems that we we were
looking at before right this b b6 square
is sort of irreparably weak we're going
to try to invade you know a5 for example
with bishop b6 ideas and then invade on
the c file looks very very good for us
but there was a single game that
followed the computer's top choice which
was c6 here
it turns out this idea is very very
difficult to to deal with
with the white pieces so
if you take on a7 this is what happened
in the game in the database black is
actually going to take on d5 and things
again get very very messy very
complicated right black is now pushing
in the center things are opening up in
the center things are getting less clear
and if you try this move d take c6 well
black's knight is very well positioned
to capture back and actually defend
against our threat on the pawn on on a7
and again things have started to open up
a little bit we haven't provoked those
key weaknesses that we were relying on
and i think black is is doing okay
um so because of this move c6 i think
knight b5 is is simply wrong
so much like
in the position uh where we were
thinking about taking on d6 but we had
this super uh super move of a4 in this
position we have a move that is going to
be very very useful to us in all the
variations and in this case that move is
knight to d3
why is knight to d3 so good well we saw
that knight b5 is a nice move aside from
this idea of c6
and after knight to d3 we are
threatening to capture on e5 and both of
black's methods of defending this pawn
makes c6 a bad idea against knight b5 so
knight d3 is so strong because we do
want to go knight b5 but it just
strengthens our position before we do so
so the easiest to understand here is
what happens if black plays knight to g6
knight to b5 and then c6
so what's wrong with this picture now oh
well okay i highlighted it with an arrow
sorry
so what's wrong with this picture now
well the knight on e7 is missing which
means we can now take on c6 there is no
knight takes c6 back defending all the
squares instead you go b c6 and bam
we're just
immediately
immediately winning the game i think
this is like plus three already uh very
very tough position for black if you try
to go bishop d7 i believe we just go
knight b4 and you are not going to be
able to keep everything together in in
this position very very tough um
so you don't go c6 here anymore
now i think black's uh
best plan is to go a6 and what are we
going to do here
we have a lot of options i think knight
a7 also wins which is why i wanted to
check but no i think knight takes d6 is
the best and again after c takes d6
we're gonna go with those those classic
plans of invading here on the queen's
side uh the computer gave a five
tentatively uh i remember looking at
this move queen b3 as well
which uh you know everything here is
going to make a lot of sense let's say
a5 following the game queen f8
again we go bishop e6 we invade on the c
file and black is going to be too slow
with the play on the king's side
so that's knight g6 i think the better
attempt here is rook to g6 trying to go
with g4
again our response is knight to b5 when
black is not going to be left with any
good options if you try c6 again it's a
little bit less obvious how c6 has been
made worse now if you take again black
has this very reasonable plan of knight
takes b knight takes c6 but in this case
we are actually able to win material by
force with knight takes d6
something takes d6 and now after bishop
c5 we're hitting this knight on e7 the
queen moves and then believe it or not
this knight is actually trapped
we go d6
your knight cannot legally move uh
without hanging itself
so we just went material by force here
rook d6 take take take and white of
course is is winning up in exchange
um
so rook g6 it turns out also prevents
black's best idea of going c6
uh so what does that mean that means
again a6 is probably black's best option
we take on d6 pawn d6 and yeah here i
was looking at at queen to b3 as well
now after g4
there's quite a few games in the
database here they all go queen b6
and black white again invades down the c
file
and
in the the game i imported uh
this position actually was reached
between
famous chess second peter high nielsen
magnus carlson's uh
main guy basically main openings guy
uh against someone named boris consular
who was 2500 back in 2001 and peter
played knight f2 which was a bad move
but bishop or just takes on g4 here is
pretty much entirely winning
again what are the ideas the ideas are
to
lock things down
on the queen side go h3 or on the king's
side if f3 gets played you go knight g4
and white is again
totally totally winning queen b7 rook c7
looks pretty convincing pretty
convincing
um
and yeah that's that's basically it we
invade on this b6 weakness like in all
the all the lines previous we bring our
rooks to the c file and try to invade
and then this is what happens if black
tries to uh to attack us queen g5 was a
better move just to show you we do go
with rook c7
and one more critical idea
this knight g4 idea is going to show up
everywhere just sort of locking things
down
for example takes takes h3
you would take and you are defending and
it's like plus a million yeah plus plus
three
plus three pretty good
okay
so how did we get here one more time we
go 93 against knight takes d6 we looked
at knight g6 and rook g6 against both
we're going knight v5 uh now c6 loses
tonight takes d6 and a6 is no good again
because of the move uh
knight takes d6 after which we attack
the b6 weakness again i wanted to look
at the one game in the database that was
in this position where white or black
played g4 just to show you here we go
bishop h4
pretty much always a good idea when um
you can you know pin this knight here
and your bishop's still on f2
and all the ideas are going to look very
very similar here black or white or
black is going to go a6 we're going to
take on d6 and again in this position
we're looking at moves like queen b3
we're looking at bringing the rook to
the c file we're looking at invading on
the queen side and black is going to
have a very tough time of dealing with
these queenside threats
once again winning opening advantage
um okay
so any questions for me here
i know we've already covered a lot but
there's a lot to cover
but the good news is white is winning
everywhere which is like awesome
any questions
okay thanks for sticking with me i know
this is dense stuff
um so before we move on to the last idea
i want to cover let's do a quick recap
of everything we've talked about
so we're looking at the king's indian
defense this is the starting position
playing the orthodox classical variation
and we're looking at this knight c6 idea
which is by far the main main move we're
going d5 locking up the center knight to
e1 the classical orthodox variations um
where we're defending our center with f3
we are attacking on the queen side black
is attacking on the king's side knight
d7 is the main move playing against our
break of c5 but this lecture we're
talking about knight e8 with the clever
idea of defending c7 and allowing the
rook to have this extra path to attack
on the king's side this is followed by
bishop e3 f5 f3 f4 bishop f2
g5 here we're looking at c5
and now we talked about how knight g6
loses to a4a5 with c6 because you don't
get g4 in time so black should go much
faster with h5 now we go a4 rook f6
again black needs to play quickly for g4
now we're taking on d6
again c takes d6 we win by provoking a
weakness with knight b5 and heading back
to attack the b6 square after knight to
d6 we can actually force very similar
positions by first playing knight d3 and
following up with knight b5 when our
plans are going to be largely the same
we attack the b6 weakness we invade on
the queen side and white has a winning
advantage so we've been talking for a
long long time
but that is what it boils down to so you
don't need to remember all the specifics
that i showed a lot of that was just
example variations of what uh
of how exactly white should invade on
the queen side how exactly to win but if
you remember those core concepts you're
going to do okay you want to go b5
provoke these weaknesses and against
knight d6 it is really important to
remember this knight to d3 idea followed
by knight to b5 when again white is
doing very very well
so
with that in mind let's look at one last
idea before we call it quits tonight
which we're going to just touch on this
briefly
which is of course
you know sort of the elephant in the
room perhaps
which is
what happens if black takes your pawn
here
so let's talk about this a little bit um
this is a very very rare idea black in
practice does this very very little
because
it doesn't make a lot of sense right you
know what is white trying to do white's
trying to open up the position on the
queen side
so why should black help you open up the
position
by you know
introducing this pawn capture wouldn't
it make more sense to make white spend
the tempo to take on d6 than to spend
the actual tempo taking on c5
and this is is kind of true uh and now
when i was analyzing this uh basically
what it boils down to is
uh most of the time eventually black is
still playing this knight to d6 move and
we are very much just transposing back
to our our c takes d6 knight takes d6
variations so i only want to talk about
this for a little bit
bishop takes c5 is gonna be the response
i recommend um it is possible with white
to ignore this pawn and not capture it
back right away but i think it's
worthwhile to to take the pawn back just
for simplicity's sake
uh black is again gonna have largely the
same ideas we want to go rook f6 h5 rook
g6 and come
try to checkmate us over here on the
king side
now here i'm going to recommend the move
a4 and the reason for that is because of
move orders because if we go c5 and
black played rook f6 first
this would be the same position right we
can play play like this here or we can
get here um
and sorry black would play h5 so we can
get here like this or we can get here
like this same position see i click back
and forth absolutely nothing changes
so i like a4 here it's still a useful
move we still want to gain this space on
the queen side and target black's queen
side pawns
and then after h5 i'm actually going to
recommend tucking this bishop back on to
f2 the reason for that is we want to
have the c5 square sort of clear for our
knight to come out and oftentimes it's
going to be very beneficial for us to
respond to the move g4 with the move
bishop h4 which is why i like having
this bishop back here on f2 in this case
g4 still hangs upon so black wouldn't do
it here but just to show you uh sort of
the the idea
and sorry i lied i'm not recommending
bishop f2 my my moves got messed up i'm
recommending knight to d3 with the idea
of going bishop to f2
so just a move order thing there i don't
think it actually matters you can go
bishop f2 here rook g693 should be
exactly the same
um
but we're going to look with with this
move order
now there is a very very high level game
in this position between boris gelfand
with white and vessel and de paulov with
black
which ended in a draw that being said
believe it or not those players played
pretty well in that game and white had a
win winning advantage so let's see how
it turned out in practice first and
foremost
g4 was played in the game and again this
bishop h4 idea is gonna come in handy uh
just pinning up the black pieces making
black's life difficult
black in this game tried a6 preventing
our ideas of knight to b5 now we go g3
and this is a really nice idea for white
to to help lock things down over here on
the king's side
so what's the idea well black plays
queen to d6 and our point is to actually
go with f takes g4 and now black plays
bishop g4 takes
and black played rook takes g4 in the
game now what happens if uh at any point
h takes g4 for example
uh what do you think is is going on here
well yeah so why why isn't black doing
this you know that that's the question
oh and yeah i forgot to answer one of
the questions in the chat so
i will get back to that before we wrap
up here
so any ideas
yeah so i've asked you a question that i
don't fully know the answer to but i
very much suspect that g takes f4 is
just winning here with knight takes f4
to follow we can go bishop g3 again
securing our king's side and at the same
time now we've we've just strictly won a
pawn in the opening not not a bad way to
play let's
let's check yeah plus plus five is
pretty good
so that's why h takes g is not getting
played and that's why g3 is such a
strong move here we are actually
threatening to just win this pawn
um
so in the game rook takes g4 was played
knight f2 was played to force this rook
back which was a good idea and now queen
takes h5 and i believe here white is
just doing very very well
um
yeah plus uh only plus one really only
plus one
uh yeah so this queen h5 move was uh not
the best it should be closer to plus two
if white finds this move king to h1
which again just sort of securing
securing the king first is is always a
good idea
um
so
that's more or less everything i want to
say about dtake c5 right and black's
best in it's in black's best interest to
sort of transpose to these knight takes
d6 lines
and it's a very inhuman idea that that
doesn't really show up in practice uh
too too often i would say but if there's
one thing that you want to look at more
engines do think that this d-take c5
move is is worth looking at and so i
would say if you're not satisfied with
the 98 coverage d-take c5 is the move
that i would go home and study now there
was one more question in the chat that i
wanted to talk about
which was basically um
i'm gonna assume it's it's from this
position the question was well if black
realizes that his attack on the king's
side isn't coming fast enough uh
wouldn't it make sense for black to try
to slow down white on the queen side and
their suggestion for that was to play
something like a6 or a5 so what do you
guys think about this move let's let's
look at a5 for example what do you think
the issue is with with this line of
reasoning
you know
why not do this to slow down white's
attack hopefully you guys understand
enough now
to be able to answer what happens if
black does something random
that's exactly right you know we go
through all this effort just to play
knight b5 to provoke a weakness and by
playing a6 or a5 black isn't really
preventing our play it's actually
advancing it now of course we can take
on d6
and we we already have our weakness
ready made to attack
so yes okay our opponent surprised us
they played a five in a position where
we didn't look at it but the ideas are
going to remain the same we want to
target the b6 square we want to invade
with our pieces
and i think there are numerous ways to
go about doing that in in this position
i actually think i would play the move
knight b1 in this position um why why
knight b1
well
i have an idea right
knight c4 and we've seen this story
before right we've seen this story
before let's ask the computer
plus three
so there you go
and
okay knight to b1 it thinks is a bit
much
um okay rook h6 is a very very strange
idea
it wants to go queen b3 though which is
a very nice idea again
targeting the weaknesses on the queen's
side and white is much much better
same thing i would say with the move a6
um
yeah queen b3 here knight d3 i think c
takes d6 is also totally fine
with again a lot of the same ideas we've
we've looked at before just invading on
the queen side going for that queen side
play
okay
any final questions for me before we
call it quits
any final questions
all right this is a pretty dense lecture
we talked about a lot uh but i think
this is going to introduce you to really
the the most important ideas in this
opening for white you you now have these
ideas a4 a5 with c5 c6 you have these c
takes d6 ideas ways to provoke
weaknesses in the queen side against the
king's indian and now hopefully we
understand why knight e8 is not a line
we see often today at the highest level
players have analyzed these variations
they see that white is sort of winning
everywhere because white's play on the
queen side is just too fast you open up
the queen side you provoke these
weaknesses and you get a winning
position
um so with that in mind look forward to
next week when we will tackle at least
some of the main variations with knight
to d7 why is knight d7 a better move
well it controls c5
okay so thank you all very very much for
watching uh if you have more time please
stick around uh international master
dorset derek shawnee will be teaching
right after this live on youtube as well
uh as always thank you so much for
joining me here tonight on the road to
2000 my name is caleb denby and we'll
see you guys next time
[Music]
you